the Federal Reserve says a resilient
economy is one reason why it's raising a
key interest rate for the second time
this year the central bank increased the
short-term rate a quarter point
yesterday to range of 1.75 to 2% if it
also predicts for rate hikes this year
after an earlier forecast of 3 CBS News
business analyst Jill Schlesinger is
here to explain what it means for you
Jill good morning good morning I read of
course the Fed chair saying this is a
sign the US economy is in great shape
but it will also mean increase interest
rates when it comes to your car your
mortgage your credit cards how big of a
jump so it's not going to be a direct
impact for every single loan you have
it's short-term loans most directly
impacted so as you say auto loans but
let's say we took a $25,000 auto loan it
may only amount to a few bucks every
month or if you look at a credit card
bill maybe you've got a 10,000 dollar
balance you're carrying same thing maybe
it's 20 bucks but these are incremental
it's been going on now since December of
2015 these rising rates I should also
note 30-year fixed-rate mortgages are
not tied to this rate directly but those
rates also have been drifting higher
that's tough for those first-time
homebuyers who are trying to get into
the market Jill what about the thing the
Fed worries about with it which is
inflation which can also take some money
out of your wallet is that part of the
concern here it is and one of the things
that the officials did was they gave us
some projections about both inflation
and economic growth and the Fed is
basically saying that growth is going to
be upgraded this year they think we're
gonna have two point eight percent
growth and just compare that with the
last five six years where it's been more
like two to two and a quarter percent
and as a result they see inflation
ticking up to a little over two percent
slightly hotter than they would like but
they're willing to keep it there this is
not great news for bit for for actual
workers out there because we haven't
seen huge wage gains so with inflation
rising with interest rates up it will
put pressure on some homes hopefully we
will get those wage gains that is the
likeliest outcome by the end of the year
Thank You Jill always good to see you
you can see you got the cream-colored
remember I got your note I got you